how's it going everyone this is
International master Daniel wrench
this is chest comms YouTube channel and
today is a Freaky Friday we're going to
be looking at some freaky openings well
maybe they're not going to be freaky but
I can say that they will give you some
of the general knowledge some of the
intro knowledge you need - one of the
chess openings if you haven't checked
out all the chess openings videos we
have and our chess openings playlist and
that's a you problem because we have
likely reviewed your opening and if you
don't have access to some potentially
more in-depth materials whether that be
an opening database or piece of software
or you know some chess books that where
you have maybe purchased a chess book on
the specific opening to play if you
don't have access to materials like that
then you should probably check out some
of those videos because the good chances
are that we've covered your opening so
let's go ahead and do this today's quick
intro opening is about the alop in
Sicilian which is an anti Sicilian what
we mean by that is that when white plays
d4 and black plays the Sicilian the main
lines of the Sicilian and there are
videos on pretty much every main line
within our chess openings playlist the
main lines of the Sicilian after Knight
of three whether black plays Knight to
c6 or d6 when white plays d4 we
officially reached an open Sicilian and
essentially this structure is defined as
white has given up the D pawn given
black to center pawns versus one but
done so for more open space and
potentially more active pieces in the
center this is just the general
philosophy behind what white is trying
to achieve with the mainline Sicilians
we've covered the knight orphan the
Dragon and the sveshnikov and all kinds
of things and the same sort of principle
applies even against nice e6 on the move
- or even potentially yz6 on the move to
the ala pin Sicilian is an anti Sicilian
starts with the move c3 and every move
that is not Knight of three and D for a
mainline Sicilian is considered an anti
Sicilian we're also going to be covering
here the Smyth more gambit as well as a
few other anti Sicilians within our
playlist the main purpose of the ala pin
is to support the move d4 so that when
white plays this pawn advance he can
recapture with upon rather than a piece
the advantage to this is that let's say
that black plays a normal move like
Knight to c6
2d6 like you would have on to night f3
as we just displayed now when white
plays d4 and this natural capture is
made instead of having a position where
white made a concession by giving up a
center pawn for activity White has made
no concessions in the center controls
more squares than black and if you go by
the classical theory of chess the
nimzowitsch theory of chess pawns on the
fourth rank are worth two points and
pawns on the sixth or third rank are
worth one point so white is potentially
going to achieve better pieces and more
control over the critical area of the
board that being the center so d4 is a
very clear idea and it's a clear threat
what could be the disadvantage of a move
like c3 well if you want to pause the
video and take a moment to guess to
improve your critical thinking skills
you can but I'll just tell you that the
issue here is that white has slowed down
his development on the queenside
particularly taking away the square for
this knight on b1 now the problem with
that is that a black knows how to
aggressively attack the center and
chooses one of the more let's say
theoretically accurate approaches to the
ala pen then white may regret having
postponed this developing move there are
two main lines and quickly before I show
them I will highlight again that normal
moves like e6000 for pawn anymore
because he's already exchanged it he's
also given white this square for the
knight because of the early exchange so
II six with d5 isn't really a real
option again as I show d6 though there
are some sidelines with d6 the main
point of just playing d6 to capture like
a regular Sicilian is going to be
insufficient pieces develop but in the
end if your opponent has much more
control over the critical area of the
board they have a lot more options and
black is potentially going to be clearly
worse and in most middle games so that's
not the best idea for the most part and
the same can be said for to Knight to c6
again after d4 takes takes if d5 is
played we have a french-style structure
but again without the real advantage of
having more pressure to increase here
and having already given white this
square on c3 and again if you
don't quite know what the French opening
is then guess what check out our check
out chess openings play this we've
already covered that as far as the
general philosophy of that pawn
structure so what black needs to do is
be a little more aggressive to punish
white for postponing this development
the two ways to do that are with Knight
to f6 attacking this pawn that would
love to be defended by the knight but
can't or to play d5 either right away or
at some point breaking the general
principle of bringing the Queen out
early but doing so because white doesn't
really have a way to tickle this Queen
out of her out of her strong post in the
center
so both d5 and Knight f6 are strong I
personally played Knight f6 on more
occasions than not attacking the e4 pawn
the disadvantage is that the pony will
lose a little bit of time we don't like
it when our ponies get kicked around but
what you've done here is induced White's
pawns forward in such a way that after
captures Knight f3 pawns not captured
well because it's pinned Knight to c6
and takes black smells natural way to
play in the center is to just simply
attack it and try to undermine these
critical points and it's very easy to
attack an extended pollen structure this
is not a French pawn structure where
your pawns have been advanced so you
have no longer any way to undermine
White's Center rather you have lots of
ways to try to undermine the center
including maybe even the fee encoder of
this Bishop where all your pieces are
sort of developing with a togetherness
and a sort of a collective purpose so
that's one way to play generally and
some of the variations can be sharp here
white also has the option of Bishop to
c4 and either Bishop b5 or Bishop to b3
sacrificing upon giving black the chance
to capture here variations like that are
sharp but also pretty equal and of
course in the main line after takes d6
Bishop c4 Knight b6 Bishop b5 again the
positions are pretty equal and playable
for both sides black not having worried
about giving these two points to white
in the center because by inducing them
forward he has the chance to undermine
them as I highlighted so that would be
one way for black to play the other way
for black to play is with d5 d5 right
away is very common and after d4 Knight
to c6 Knight f3 in many cases we head to
a pretty standard isolated queen pawn
position with black eventually capturing
here losing some time with his queen and
white potentially having
more active and aggressive development
however black is in a position to exert
long-term pressure against white centre
pollen there's actually a video on the
theory of that type of position on our
main site on Ches calm this weekend in
fact the other way to play it and one
that comes as a personal recommendation
of Grandmaster Roman Jim G house really
a lot of people know him from Romans lab
and he's an author for us on Ches comm
with the move to g6 with the idea of
meeting this position with d5 the
difference being then then a normal
French for example where this would be
happy is that black has not played East
6 yet what that does is in a lot of
positions on top of just developing
normally at some point he wants to get
this Bishop outside the pawn chain maybe
even trade it for a knight on f3 which
will increase his pressure on d4 the
lines are complicated and again you have
to know the theory but as far as a
general outlook in terms of the purpose
of the ala pen being to achieve this
positional advantage without any sort of
sacrifice in the center and Black's
different ways to counter-attacked it
then I think we did a pretty good job
here as far as giving a general in show
into this opening so I put on my best
serious pants for you guys today my
serious Sally face my Nancy pants no
more crazy jokes you know for all you
lame people out there if you're no fun
in life that I'm sure you enjoy this
video just kidding
but I'm not kidding don't worry you're
all smart enough and good enough go take
a look in the mirror Stuart Smalley and
I will see you around on chess calm